here in my 10 million dollar studio got
the flying lamborghini here but you know
what i like more than
flying lamborghinis tick tock investors
traders
people who are teaching me look tick
tock's my new bloomberg terminal forget
about it for gen
z dude this is how they learn about
finance and maybe we can learn
about gen z through fin talk guys
let's uh let's let's take a look at what
their new analysts are saying the next
warren buffett if you will up first we
have
a dogecoin guys we're gonna be hearing a
lot about this
it's one of tick tocks favorite
investments they call it some would call
it gambling but who
am i right i don't have a million
followers on tick tock
it's time to listen to the real pros if
you think dogecoin hitting 60 cents
today is crazy
wait till you hear this many analysts
including myself believe that doge has
the potential to be equal with
ethereum first of all who are these
other analysts and
who are you i looked this guy up on tick
tock
and he says he's 16 years old the 16
year old analyst sorry
go ahead how rude of me to interrupt you
that think it sounds crazy because of
doge's market cap
wait till you hear this both doge and
ethereum have essentially the same
endless market cap and if you keep
digging all aspects of both coins are
virtually the same
i used to say i'd give it a year to hit
the price of ethereum
but with the way doge is going right now
we could see this in less than a few
months
oh it hurts so much
this is what happens when you're raised
on a diet of pizza rolls and other
tick tock analysts okay the first rule
of crypto by the way
i've learned just now you have to be an
absolute idiot
and project stupid impossible numbers
just for the record guys
if dogecoin goes up to three thousand
dollars
first of all it's gonna be worth several
times ethereum because dogecoin just has
more coins than ethereum does so if it
matched the price gonna be worth
way more but also it's gonna be worth
more than apple
netflix microsoft all combined guys just
a 300 trillion dollar market cap
no big deal both doge and ethereum have
essentially the same endless market cap
by the way doge and ethereum are nothing
alike and don't let anyone tell you
otherwise doge is a meme
it's a literal joke aetherium is a
decentralized computer
you know what i'm an idiot for trying to
make sense of this guys i'm talking to
an astros analyst here
many analysts including myself believe
that
i honestly do think this is a brilliant
video though because you can start
anything with that many analysts
including myself think that this guy's
an idiot because i think what we can
take away from that last video is that
no one should be
investing in dogecoin so you took 180
000 right correct this was your life
savings
you sold stocks you borrowed money on
margin
you maxed out your credit cards and you
just yellowed all that money into
dogecoin
correct yeah what an idiot why though
because there's those
robin hood okay portfolio i want to see
how much your dogecoin is worth
right now right this second here you go
jesus it is worth
1.25 million dollars
okay i take it all back guys i'm
investing my life savings into doge
and i'm an idiot for not trusting see
this is what i mean you got to trust the
financial analyst of tick tock there we
go
second mortgage on my house and bye
uh dogecoin is where i'm putting all my
money now i'm sorry for ever doubting
you guys now what can i expect from my
new investment
dogecoin is blowing up it's at 33 cents
right now and it's stabilizing around
the 30 cent area
but i think dogecoin is about to do
something even greater it's going to
substantially multiply
that's actually a new financial
investment word
phrase it's substantially multiplying we
don't talk about any kind of ratios
we don't talk about math we talk about
substantially multiplying your eyebrows
have to be like this
guys a doge is 30 cents but i think it's
going to
substantially multiply eventually
multiply on april 20th
4 20 really dude aka
420. i have a feeling elon musk is going
to put out a tweet
dude that's the new financial analyst
like think it's like
it's not like a strong earnings call
it's yo i think elon musk is about to
tweet
hey guys that's most of cr crypto now
hey dude i think the tokenomics are
strong with this one really
what does this crypto do i think elon
musk's about to tweet about it that's
what they do
it's 4 20 and elon musk is about to
tweet
and use some of his money to invest in
doge driving the price up
if this goes as planned and everybody
including mr musk go ahead and just pour
money into doge on april 20th all at
once
those will reach prices that originally
were not even conceptual
not even originally conceptual this
guy's analysis is basically if
all of us throw our entire bank accounts
at this coin
price go up when we all throw money at
the same thing
i don't think he's ever anyway i'm not
not even trying to hate on this guy this
is just
the level we're at it's a this is what
you get with a 16 year old analyst
and honestly am i the right one here
because i'm the one who missed out on
millions of dollars apparently
and when doge hits a thousand dollars i
will be the one crying but i don't want
to give you guys the impression that
everything's just about crypto on tick
tock
there's all sorts of financial
investments and there are a lot of rich
people too
tell me that you're extremely wealthy
without telling me that you're stupid
[Music]
what what is this
i have nothing to say this guy's a chat
he's richer than all of us
he could probably buy nikola with the
price of this wood
being what it is right now in fact i
think this is the new investment
i mean wood's going to match the price
of ethereum very quickly
at one flank of wood going to 3 000 guys
what's next
the real estate market dude i actually
like this one this is actually true
this is tick tock at its best right here
i think bidding starts at five dollars
feeling pretty confident there huh i
mean ten dollars he said starting at
five
fifteen is this a new apple yeah just
listed i'm pre-qualified i'll pay cash i
get cash
20. no just make it 45. is it even worth
that
50. i don't know please this is the
eighth apple i've tried to buy i at
least see it up close
nope it's an apple you know what it is
you either want it or you don't i'll
take it for 100. what i'm from
california it's the cheapest apple i've
ever seen
yeah it's basically the market right now
in texas at least it's because of all
you californians once again
ruining everything they're all coming to
texas joe rogan
announces his move and all of a sudden
it's just everybody's coming in and
they're selling their million dollar
houses
and they're just driving the price way
up i i mean if you're going to buy a
house
basically anywhere in the south right
now you better be willing to sell your
firstborn
both your legs because that's the only
way you're going to get into even a
hut at this point it's ridiculous now up
next we have everyone who recently
sold a house a couple weeks i haven't
had any time to take for myself
so i figured tonight i'm just gonna go
chill on my yacht and uh
take it easy yeah you sell one house
you're like i'm rich
now oh do you guys not have a yacht
it's cause you're poor
this is also anyone who just got a
stimulus check that's how everyone felt
when they got their stimulus checked
am i rich now it's like that meme is
this wealth
uh i could literally purchase every
goddamn one of you and sell you at a
garage sale
[Laughter]
oh dude this is some weird mix of a frat
guy
with cocaine with uh yeah stimulus
checks
i think what i admire most about tic toc
is just the raw
level of energy it's completely
unmatched and what they lack
in expertise they make up for in
screaming do you know why i got this
boat
i sold stocks and i made money you guys
are probably like wait
where's the catch is he trying to sell
us a course or something no
i'm here to call you poor and me rich
money money
money uh yeah well that you fit in well
my friend you fit in very well i'm
pretty sure he did try to sell us a
course
with the forex thing but we'll let that
pass let's go to the next one oh man i
remember this guy speaking of cocaine
let's start getting weak we got a nice
little double top going across the board
right here oh nice little double top
looking for a crack and let's see 161's
right now
now again we're getting there let's get
that 161 crack let's go let's go
let's see the 160 crack let's see it
start going on down baby
c160 go we got last trade right here 160
let's go
let's crack let's dump let's see this
one fall currently up 8 000.
is this that guy just screaming random
words in the dictionary let's crack
let's go come on baby let's go on down
we know again you're cracking the trend
line
let's go let's go on down let's lock out
a little bit right here
let's see this one keep on falling 157
let's keep it going on down baby we're
cracking
trend lines and let's just lock it on up
baby let's just lock it on up and take
50 thousand dollars
in a day you guys actually can't see it
because he cut off the video early
three seconds later he had a stroke
what's crazy dude like
this level of energy it's like a casino
you see this at the crab team like let's
go
let's go oh man it's like jordan belfort
levels wolf of wall street levels of
just like psycho
beating yourself in the head with money
i'm pretty sure that's what all the
famous investors did that's like i'm
pretty sure jack bogle
and peter lynch do that too oh this
one's kind of interesting okay
because look okay the glass is dead
giveaway
we're talking to an analyst here good
morning everybody
i took up a little bit of a new hobby
and i'm kind of interested
in day trading so last week i
it's like saying hey guys took up a new
hobby i'm kind of interested in particle
physics on the side guys i think that's
going to be my new like side hustle i
bought some stock in amc
i bought it at about 15 a share um i've
been waiting for the dip
and this morning we're down to 11 51 so
i snatched up some more
over the weekend theaters opened in
california and they have been selling
out
all show times um people on youtube
are saying that this could be the next
game stop and they're predicting that
shares could go for two thousand oh the
only thing worse
than tick tock advice is probably
youtube advice this is the next gamestop
guys this is the next big bull run
guys let's all yolo into amc look
let me just tell you guys this right now
there's an old saying that if your
cabbie is telling you about
uh you know stocks you need to sell we
need a new say
if a brand new trader is telling you
about uh
things like to the moon what i heard
from you know youtubers stuff like this
it's time to sell baby the hype is over
but what do i know guys i'm not a tick
tock investor here and besides the
market doesn't make any sense anyway
[Applause]
so i did something oh
i started a crypto token called
dude i guarantee this is worth a million
dollars oh i'm dumb it says right there
okay well see i i low bought it with it
but it's been maybe like
10 hours and almost 3 000
people hold this coin now it's worth
we're not in a bubble guys
get this not in a bubble a 5.4
8 million market cap dude i mean like
honestly this is amateur numbers these
are rookie numbers we talked to somebody
billion dollar market cap
in like 30 minutes so i don't know what
you're doing
i love our like five million dollars not
impressive honestly
weak sheesh doesn't have those
tokenomics baby doesn't have the pump of
mentals
let's get let's get out of here this
guy's broke i don't have time for
for millionaires okay i need
billionaires who's this guy uh oh
i know this guy matt lauren we've seen
him in other videos here ron must
tweeted if there's ever a scandal about
me please call it elon
hold on guys elon musk tweeted stop the
presses
financial markets are moving literally
right after that tweet was made there
was a new cryptocurrency release that's
about to skyrocket immediately i went
and bought seven
trillion elongate why they just invaded
it because of an elon musk tweet and you
bought seven
trillion coins what did that cost five
dollars
dude these coins are so stupid i say
this was just released
i'm talking about literally today is the
best part whenever elon musk tweets
about dogecoin it goes absolutely crazy
just to give you some perspective
this is elon gate right now hey guys
we're all waiting for
elon musk to tweet about it guys it's
going to be huge is that what he's going
to say
about a month after its release now
imagine elon musk he tweets about oh my
gosh dude
you have to laugh or you're going to cry
that this is the state
of financial analysis on tick-tock on
all of these platforms
we've truly left all synths behind and i
for one
am looking forward to the crash and burn
you know honestly it's a big question
like what do you do
in these crazy markets do you just give
in to the insanity or do you like kind
of wait and be like
you're gonna get it eventually you kids
and then they're like hey i made three
thousand percent yesterday and you're
like
like that guy with doge it's like doge
is a joke guy makes a million dollars
with it
i don't know i stick with the
fundamentals but uh i know a lot of
people who are giving in to the yellow
baby
they're like hey why not buy 7 trillion
elongate who knows
i guess this is our last one what is
this the other day i promoted a
cryptocurrency named mando
which the developers pretty much scammed
everyone including me
and this is why you go with fundamentals
guys this is the same guy permeating
promoting elon gate or whatever seven
trillion he would have scammed you if
you had invested with
mando of course busted into mando and
also myself i had ten thousand dollars
invested
which all of it is gone now look dude at
some point if you're looking for like
three thousand percent gains
you're gonna get rug pull honestly this
is just what happens you're not gonna
get into a three
it's like penny stocks all over again
and i don't think a lot of people have
recognized that
going into all these all coins it's like
buying pink sheets i mean it's like it's
the same thing all over again just
people haven't learned their lesson yet
i don't know
we'll see but you know what guys why am
i hating
we've been through a journey together
and it's time to respect the pump right
we've got dogecoin is it going to three
thousand dollars we've learned lessons
about investing
maybe some people are making millions of
dollars oh wait
there's still a lot of idiots out there
we've got you know wood investors we've
got
just objectively rich people who could
buy you and sell you in a garage sale we
even have
real estate investors all in all i would
say that the analysis on tick-tock
it's booming right now guys and millions
are listening whether or not they should
be
what do you think do you think that
we're in in a new time
where memeonomics tokenomics are taking
over
fundamentals don't matter or do you
think we're headed towards the cliff and
about to fall off
i don't know i'll leave it for you guys
on tick tock to decide i'm just your
humble commentator your humble
guide through these things i feel like
that guy on uh
marvel the avengers like i lead others
to a treasure that i cannot possess okay
so you guys let me know what's gonna
happen next thanks for watching i
appreciate you
and i'll see you in the next episode of
tick tock idiots sorry
investors see you later
nothing but a trick trying to sell me on
a dream but that was where you lost me